مطار هيثرو لندن هو واحد من
أكثر المطارات ازدحامًا في العالم ، حيث تمر مائة مليون حقيبة
كل عام عبر هذا الفراشة الصغيرة للطيران ،
وهي واحدة من أكبر المهام التي تواجهها
شركة الطيران والمطار على حد سواء بالطبع ،
مع التأكد من وصول البنوك إلى حيث
تحتاج إلى الذهاب بشكل صحيح ،
لذا بمجرد الحقيبة  يذهب إلى أين
يذهب في رحلة طويلة على هذا
النحو ، سوف يلقي نظرة ويرى إلى
أين سيذهب بعد أن تكون حسنًا ، ما
يحدث هنا هو فقط يتابع على حزام النقل
بأكياس من رحلات أخرى
تنضم من هناك إلى أعماق الظلام
أحشاء نظام الأمتعة ،
مقدار العملية التي تتم بشكل آلي ، فهي مؤتمتة بنسبة 98 ٪
ويمكن للنظام نفسه
التعامل مع أربعة أو خمسة آلاف حقيبة في
الساعة وهذا لمدة 18 ساعة تقريبًا
كل يوم ، لذا فإن هذه الحقيبة ستذهب إلى
شارلوت ثم كانتاس بيرج
سأذهب إلى دبي وهذا سينتهي به المطاف
في سنغافورة ، سنغافورة ، في الوقت
الذي يجب أن أفكر فيه غدًا في
الانضمام إلى 13 كيلومترًا من
أحزمة النقل المتكاملة الآلية التي تهبط هنا
بعد دقائق  في صالة التحميل ، لذا فإن
هذا الحزام يقوم الآن بعمل أتلانتا وميامي ،
نعم ،
حقيبة خاطئة ، طائرة خاطئة ، لا فماذا
سيحدث هو الرجال الذين يحملون الماسح الضوئي هنا
عندما يقومون بمسح هذه الحقيبة بحثًا عن
الرحلة والبصل الأخضر الذي كانوا عليه إذا
حاولوا و  قم بتحميل ذلك على حاوية
لرحلة أتلانتا ، فستحصل على مطالبة
ولن تسمح لهم بذلك
، ثم الحاوية الموجودة على عربة
لنقلهم إلى الطائرة المنتظرة ، لا
يهم مقدار الأتمتة التي تنطوي
عليها في النهاية ، تنتهي دائمًا  مع
شخص ما يجب أن يدفعها
لك